[Music]
good evening and welcome to the half
king reading series my name is Glenn
Rauscher the host and curator of this
series here at the half King we aim to
bring you the best authors and books
with a unifying factor that they're all
vital critical thought-provoking works
that will stimulate thought and
discussion not just in this room but
stay with you after you've left us we
are extremely pleased to welcome amanda
marcotte who will join us momentarily to
discuss her book troll nation we're also
happy to have c-span here taping us
tonight
what Thank You c-span when when the when
the actual showing is scheduled we will
put that word out on our various
channels we do want you to participate
in the conversation we're going to have
this evening we do have a request
however please form your thoughts in the
shape of a question if you cannot form
your thought in the shape of a question
I will move along to someone who can and
give you the time to change that into a
question so again please help us help
you help us have a great event by doing
that we are we do have copies of troll
nation here tonight for sale from books
on call NYC New York's premier
independent off-site bookseller the book
is not out so when you buy your copies
plural tonight by New York law you will
have something that no one else on the
planet is able to get for another 8 or
so days so again please pick up a copy
of the book Amanda will be happy to sign
copies for you after the event we'd also
like to thank our friends at skyhorse
publishing for their assistant with
assistance with tonight's event and for
publishing the book in the first place
please do take care of your servers they
work very hard to bring you your vittles
and your beverages without which this
would be a much drier literally and
figuratively evening coming up at the
half King we are in week 3 of 8 weeks in
a row of amazing authors and
so I won't list them all the half King
website has everything we're doing with
your Memorial Day just a little taste of
what we're doing the next couple weeks
next Monday April 23rd John Sedgwick
joins us for his book blood moon about
the rivalry between two legendary
Cherokee Treves and the effect it had on
the Cherokee Nation and on April 30th
were joined by journalist Carmen
Gentilly another skyhorse author as a
matter of fact to discuss his book
blindsided by the Taliban detailing his
war reporting and his wounding which
cost him the sight in his right eye all
our events begin on seven o'clock most
of them are on Mondays we've got a
couple of Tuesday events check the
calendar again there are 10,000 other
places you could be on any given night
here in New York City and no one
involved with this event or any of the
events we do here at the half King takes
for granted that you've chosen to be
here with us so thank you very much for
that and now to this evenings featured
author with intelligence a keen eye for
detail and razor-sharp wit that brings
to mind the great molly ivins about whom
it was said she was rowdy and profane
but she couldn't fillet her opponents
withdrawal precision thus it is here as
well
amanda marcotte stroll nation take
surgical aim at the corrosive elements
of right-wing politics that led to the
election and administration of America's
greatest troll Donald Trump she
thoroughly examines how we got into this
situation and with many different
opinions on how to deal with troll
nation how best to do so engage or not
engage protest against speakers like
Charles Marie
Milo you nopales her Ann Coulter on
college campuses or allow their ideas to
be heard denying them and their
followers their cherished victim martyr
status especially when the actual
content of their ideas is little more
than at hominem as' insults she
incisively examines debunking versus
ignoring and follows that further into
motivation and intent to try to figure
out ways to better understand trolling
without stepping into arguments where
facts cannot be agreed upon she rightly
points out the thinness of troll
nation's ID
and how in Trump they found a leader who
shares their contempt for empirical
truth and gives them the easy shocks
they get off on but also warns that
trolls with access to the very highest
levels of power regardless of their
motivation are in position to and have
done tremendous harm to society and our
long cherished ideas of fairness justice
and a sense of community in chapters
that in turn address specific issues
like women's rights the environment
health care guns etc Amanda spells out
how trolls have entered the discussion
not with reasoned arguments facts and
data but with a singular focus on
discomforting liberals notwithstanding
the damage the policies they claim to
support like denial of contraception
removal of environmental regulations and
corporate giveaways due to the mostly
conservative communities they ostensibly
claim to represent she persuasively
argues that there is a way out and while
she says that she and most people who
share a liberal perspective would love
to find troll nation reachable she
writes you can't reason someone out of a
position they didn't reason themselves
into but they can be outvoted if
liberals are willing to actually show up
at the polls the failure to do so risks
allowing authoritarian viewpoints to
prevail with a motivated base who will
turn out and will regardless of the
damage that ensues even to themselves
enthusiastically support policies that
further further marginalize already
marginalized groups
it's the nihilistic view that it's more
important that those they despise suffer
than they win with troll nation amanda
marcotte continues and extends a great
tradition of political writing there are
two kinds of humor molly ivins told
People magazine one was the kind quote
that makes us chuckle about our foibles
and our shared humanity she said the
other kind holds people up to public
contempt and ridicule that's what I do
this is where you can tell the truth
with the bark on it laugh at anyone who
is ridiculous and go after the bad guys
with all the energy you have
please welcome Amanda Marcotte you've
already done it so thank you so much for
coming so as I'm reading the book I
realized like the worst thing you can do
to a troll is is laugh at them how did
how does that factor into trolling and
and the president's actions and you're
in your mind that's an interesting
question because I do think that Donald
Trump has kind of created his own
personal hell in a lot of ways for
himself right here's a man who probably
ran for president cuz he was angry at
Obama laughing at him
and now he's the most laughed at person
on the planet
so I mean but I do think also that a lot
of people that are into trolling they
have these are at least that kind of
right wing type trolling they have a lot
of privilege white male privilege and a
lot of social status that accrues from
it and so they don't necessarily grasp
sometimes how much they're being laughed
at is it is it the lack of
self-awareness or is it willful I mean
certainly willful in that sense but I
also do think that III never stop being
amazed when I'm online and how many men
that come at me on Twitter and whatnot
don't seem to grasp that women can be
funny or that women can make fun of them
like I think it's just a category error
on their part because is it because they
essentially have a circumscribed view of
what what women can do in this
particular case exactly yeah they just
don't think of women as people that
generate humor that's something men do
and so you can just sit there and make
fun of them all day and they'll just be
better they're Russians I mean it might
just be translation issue there's
there's a rather well-known internet
saying which is don't feed the trolls
and I know that in the book you wrestle
with the idea of responding not
responding Toma tell me your thoughts
about that that very concept well I can
I continue to wrestle with it I don't
know that I'm ever going to have the
answer to this question and I know
that's a disappointing thing to say cuz
you read books for answers so there's
more in this book than this but I think
that there's a problem especially with
this kind of right-wing trolling like
you mentioned Charles Marie Ann Coulter
Milo Ian AAPIs coming to campus is there
only brought there in a sense to troll
but they also have ideas about racism
sexism they are pushing bigoted notions
and I do think there is a danger that if
you don't meet people making bigoted
arguments with resistance then they will
interpret that as community ascent right
and so and I think there's some evidence
to back this up like white supremacist
if they don't get counter protest and
sometimes feel like they've been
validated as they're speaking for the
community so I do think that people
whose instinct is to meet these kind of
trolls in public and to confront them
and to argue with them or doing the
right thing so the question is how can
we do that without feeding their victim
complex and without them leaning on
their other narrative which is we're
martyrs they're trying to censor us
they're politically correct etc etc and
I don't know that there's ever one right
answer but I do think that having really
hash this out with a number of people
including some folks that
Southern Poverty Law Center what I've
come around to feel is that the best way
to deal with them is to bring them the
debate that they claim they want but
they don't actually want and you know
maybe not it's go shout somebody down
but stay outside their event and hand
out literature or talk to some people
about what your views are and just try
to actually make positive idea based
arguments it's not sexy but it works and
that's and that's that's different from
I think what we see a lot in the news
where mmm
mainstream journalists I think this is I
wanted to ask you about both sides ISM a
little bit where mainstream journalists
seem to seek out not the the extreme
cases that think that you speak about a
control nation but the idea that you
have to find every single Trump voter
and find out what they think with not
necessarily a counterweight is there is
there is is there a forum where you can
actually hear those ideas and counter
them or is it everything so siloed right
now you know I don't know if things are
as siloed as we think especially in the
era of social media I think that we can
go out there and look and people are
having conversations again across
partisan lines every day what I think my
objections to some of that let's go out
to you know rural America and talk to
some working-class Trump supporters type
stories is is that they distort the
realities of what's going on when they
should be illuminating those realities
for one thing we know that the majority
of Trump voters are not working class
they are middle class or they are upper
class that actually the average Trump
voter makes a lot more money than the
average Clinton voter and I think that
therefore they buy by pushing this
narrative that the average Trump voter
is a working-class person they hide the
fact that actually what the average
Trump voter is is a white person that's
like what holds that coalition together
not not class status or
of that nature does that answer your
question the truth is one of the things
you talk about in the book I found
fascinating was tribal epistemology you
talk about that a little bit well I
don't use big words like epistemology
it's in the book I swear I know what
page it is maybe you're quoting someone
that's [ __ ] yes yeah it's probably
quitting the robbers yeah and it's
actually one of the things I think is
most interesting and I think I I feed
the the right-wing tribe as it exists
now has only kind of forms in a cohesive
way in the past few decades
it's like a lot of the people that are
kind of in the right wing tribe and have
the sort of tribal allegiance to being a
Republican or being a conservative or
whatever else you want to call it I
don't know that they would have thought
of themselves as a tribe that was
opposed to liberals who they identify as
a separate tribe 30 years ago or 40
years ago but now I think we have siloed
off into tribal identities in a lot of
ways and so much of what makes troll
nation exists is that they have a notion
of themselves as a group of people that
has their own identity
you know tribal identity and I think
that isn't to say that they didn't that
they don't have an allegiance to certain
older kinds of ways of being in the past
it's just that that kind of white
Christian Protestant hegemony like of
the past was just that it wasn't
challenged the notion that that was the
equivalent of American like wasn't
challenged until the past couple of
decades where people of color people who
sort of disagree with this kind of
traditionalist worldview all sorted
iversity of America is really starting
to exert itself and despite their their
basic centrism or his basic set RISM
that means obama has to come as quite a
shock to these people
yes and actually I think that helped
form it's not just Barack Obama like Fox
News Rush Limbaugh there's been all
these forces like reaching out to a
certain kind of like white American and
trying to convince them they're a member
of a tribe opposed to these other people
for decades now Barack Obama however did
seem like an alien to you know the kind
of white people I grew up with out like
rural Texas you know they've never met
somebody with a name like Barack Obama
they don't know that many black people
to begin with and so the idea that
somebody like that can be supported
enough to become president must have
felt like a shock to their system it
must have felt like they didn't that
this country was not the one that they
they know so I don't like to wait to the
end to open it up to questions
so I'd like to start right here so what
I'll do is if you have a question I'll
make sure everybody can hear it and I
may repeat it so if you do have a
question just throw your hand in the air
don't start with you folks hi go right
ahead what do you make this I'm the one
that we decry the meanness which we call
mindless Venus of the right controls and
yet we adore Molly Ana's who is
self-described as mean like she's on our
side
so how do we feel their job thanks
when you say so so the question was
anything everybody heard it it's like
how do you deal with what it can be
potentially described as sort of
meanness on a side that politically you
agree with that's a really good question
and something I think that has been
coming up a lot especially I think as
there is a sense that hatred and anger
is sort of escalating in this country
but really in this book I'm trying to
argue not against meanness or you know
invective even really I use both those
things myself a lot effectively but um
more than emptiness of it I think what
the difference to me is that the right
has lost all sense of arguments or basis
of argument that they've they've lost
the culture war arguments they've lost
the economic arguments they've lost the
scientific arguments and so all that's
left is anger invective resentment and a
desire for revenge
I don't see the evidence that that's
true on the left yes people on love can
be mean I can be mean they can be
insulting but I have an idea of like a
set of policy ideas that I believe in a
set of principles that I believe in and
at the end of the day I think most of
them would actually help most
conservative Americans who also need
clean air clean water to you know
breathe and drink they could use
healthcare to Obama care they could use
the social safety net so I think the
difference is I don't think liberal
politics are at their core about
punishing the right simply for existing
and I don't think the reverse is true
you meant you mentioned in the book an
amazing set of statistics in terms of
policies people actually support when
they're asked I can't remember like wait
you're not gonna you're gonna quote the
numbers but it's it is kind of
remarkable I mean maybe it seems back to
be you know what's the matter with
Kansas idea where people vote against
their their own interests well define
own interest and I think that's where I
really disagree with Thomas Frank like
he I think he correctly assessed that
culture war politics are often a
distraction
in a way from economic policies and
politics so I agree with him on that but
what I disagree with is he I think buys
into an argument that a lot on the left
a lot of us on the Left buy into which
is that therefore culture war politics
aren't real right that that what people
are getting out of the sort of racial
bigotry and sexism and and you know
flag-waving nationalism or whatever kind
of cultural war politics you want to
decry today that that's meaningless and
not obviously I think that's
condescending as an argument I think
that it is under estimating what
conservative Americans are sort of
basing the worldview it on to a certain
extent I mean I do think that they get
something out of it I don't think
they're idiots and I think you know you
can make an argument that it's maybe
that they just don't have anything else
I think there is about validity to that
and I kind of try to make that argument
in this but I think ultimately like that
sense of self-esteem that they get from
feeling kind of superior is not
something to underestimate you break
down the famous quotation from Barack
Obama when he talked about clinging to
guns and religion and you say that that
that was that might be an example of
what you're talking about because the
the entire quote I think speaks to what
you're what you're addressing right now
yeah and he got raked over the coals I
think and it's actually one of those
kind of perfect examples of the thesis
of this book Obama made a speech that I
felt like was at its core very
sympathetic to right-wing America like
he said that they feel caught out the
kind of Trump voters that the new york
times are romanticizes they feel cut out
of
American mainstream they feel like
they're being left or right behind by
the world therefore they cling to their
guns and their God and they and their
bitter right and I think he was
accurately assessing them and they are
so angry about it they call it like you
if you go on right-wing sites you'll
often see them identify themselves as
bitter clingers and and like it's the
the angerness it's like it proves it
right that like the bitterness of that
sort of proves his point and yet they
think they're retaliating against it or
maybe you do they may be I think there's
sort of an admission it's true and yet a
desire to to punish and win anyway it's
a little incoherent but I think that
tells us a lot about the politics we're
at now but I think that that the
butchering of that full sentiment and
also in the last political race the
butchering of the speech where Hillary
Clinton referred to basket of deplorable
's
really problematic was presented in full
maybe it still would make no difference
because people won't hear what they want
to hear but I wanted to ask you about
both both sides ISM and how that that
damages the the discourse and in and I
think inadvertently plays into into
troll nation yeah I mean one of the
things that advantages troll nation is
the both sigh tourism and I understand
why mainstream journalists wants to seem
fair and even-handed and so it's created
this myth that if the right does
something then the left must do it in an
equal measure right so if the right
Alexa Donald Trump I don't know the left
made some you know Oliver Stone
president or something
but the obviously yeah but that it
obviously didn't happen but you see the
similar kind of rhetoric kind of going
on and and the right sort of knows that
they do this and sort of exploit it it
kind of is a permission slip for them to
go as far as they want to and be as
ridiculous as they want to because on
some level they know journalists are
gonna try to normalize that by saying
well that's just politics both sides do
it in equal measure Donald Trump is a
master at this actually he is constantly
craving these false equivalences more
questions please over here so the
question is the differencing idea based
and fact-based arguments that's a good
question you know I think an idea based
when I would talk about idea based
arguments I think it's a it's very much
around like what your values are and
what you think will accomplish those
values what your stated values are and
how your policies or ideas will
generally fulfill it so when I say that
the left has is still an idea based kind
of thing I think we have certain ideas
we think people should be equal and
therefore we have some policy ideas
about that we feel things like health
care and shelter our rights so we create
policy ideas based around that and it's
not that the right hasn't done that
traditionally and I think to a certain
extent still does you know it's just I
think a lot of their ideas have failed
and they haven't been able to come up
with new ones and so all that's left is
this sort of vortex of Neill ISM and
anger you know and
and I know that sounds extreme but it's
true I mean you think about like what
were some of the classic right-wing
arguments some traditional family values
like that's like a legitimate argument I
don't agree with it but like the notion
that men have rolled and women have a
roll and it creates stability in the
home and that that's a desirable thing
that that's an argument but it's not one
that makes sense when you elect Donald
Trump thrice-married multiple adulterer
to the presidency right
it shows they've given up on that and of
course they've given up on it in red
America people are living their lives
that in a way that shows that they've
given up on the idea of the traditional
family structure like they have
premarital sex they get divorced more
than in blue states it's they've lost
that argument so instead they're just
angry and they're gonna elect this like
open learing misogynist that sort of
lays naked what was always kind of I
feel a little bit underneath that more
questions please
right here one thing I think is that the
right to patrols take a lot of pleasure
in being outrageous and I think they
think that the left gets to be
outrageous like we get your [ __ ] hats
and make it you know it's queer
outrageousness and so they want to be
outrageous to choose so there's weird
way that feel that there's nice
mimicking identity what they think
identity politics honor
so I guess but they also care grab that
ng politics is punitive and join lettuce
and humerus so I was just curious gonna
be thoughts about like can the left
count on the pleasure or like do you
that there is this kind of year
nevertheless sometimes or what the
American ellipse to do that they don't
get to do I think it's a really good
observation and absolutely like jealousy
and biting people style is a huge part
of I think what is driving this kind of
alt right way of thinking about politics
and it goes back to that what about ISM
that he was talking about this both
cider ISM and I do joke often that like
I think more right-wingers now have read
Saul Alinsky's rules for radicals like
the people on the left and they are kind
of borrowing I think to great effects
some of his ideas they're not wrong that
humor and trolling are effective
political strategies and I would be the
first to say that used correctly like
trolling can actually work as a
political strategy my question is when
you what are you trolling for like what
is your end goal like what are your
actual values and I think that's where
the the big difference is I think
trolling has become an end in and of
itself on the right just sticking it to
liberals has become the end whereas
ideally if you're doing a Solinsky style
troll it's to turn to people's attention
to a positive change you want to see in
society does that I hope that answers
your question
pretty defined trolling
like online harassment and you know with
like I view those personally and very
differently but I'm curious it like what
your your base Terrier earliness
explain it so the question is what is
the baseline definition of troll I mean
the most basic form of trolling is is
being deliberately provocative to get a
rise out of somebody else you know so
that you can kind of make a spectacle
out of their their reaction right I
think that's kind of where trolling has
begun like especially on the alt-right
that drew a lot of people in and it's a
kind of it's an inherently a sadistic
act right you're trying to make somebody
else look like a fool by like provoking
them to act in a way that you think
looks a melee ating for them and it is
clear to me that that is why that's kind
of why I wanted to go with this for the
book because I feel like above all other
things
voting for Donald Trump was an act of
trolling like the whole point of voting
for Donald Trump is because you feel
like it's going to anger liberals and
make them mad and then you can mock
their liberal tears and there's
snowflake reactions and you know I think
there's more to kind of like the the
sadism and desire to punish and and
humiliate your opponents but ultimately
why I wanted to use the sort of troll
mentality was I wanted to like
expression I think a lot of liberals
have which is what motivated that desire
to vote for Trump in the first place
especially is like those who voted for
him in the primaries I wanted to ask you
about sort of the in terms of the book
itself obviously you write a tremendous
amount how did you approach writing the
book differently than let's say the
number of articles you write essays you
write
hmm well I was lucky to be writing as a
journalist for salon while I was writing
this lucky in the sense that it kept me
sort of constantly doing research that I
could then use in cannibalise for the
book not lucky in the sense that working
all day and then going home to write at
night is that's a lot of work
I didn't I because the book is like on
the sky horse hot books label it's
supposed to be short it's supposed to be
analytical I wasn't able to do like a
lot of independent research for the book
but I was lucky that being a journalist
means I already had that on file what
was the biggest pathology man into
writing the book and how did you get
around it my biggest concern I would say
is that everything is moving so fast in
the new cycle right now that you feel
like you file it and it's not coming out
for a few months and so much other crazy
stuff is gonna happen so I acknowledge
it in the book and I try to make it
clear that I feel like all these trends
that I'm sort of identifying are
probably going to continue because I
will say the one thing that's true about
Donald Trump as a man and his people as
supporter the supporters as people is
that their behavior is I think
predictable and so as crazy as a new
cycle gets I think you can kind of
predict everything that they're gonna do
and react because of past behavior more
questions please here
sort of degradation a sense of shared
reality of shared facts that you've only
three out I guess the 80s
we no longer out on a green reality
so the question was having an agreed
reality that we all buy into the role of
trolls then and I was gonna ask about
the concept of devaluing the truth that
you write about in the book I've thought
about this a lot and I have a chapter
about conspiracy theories in particular
and I think that troll nation and
trolling has actually made it easier for
conspiracy theories to take off not just
in terms of like the social media
structures that spread them but also the
way of thinking about politics like if
all you care about is getting a rise out
of your opponents humiliating them and
just winning at all cost then things
like truth and facts don't matter
anymore and what I find interesting
watching trolls like conspiracy theory
trolls like Alex Jones and Mike Stern of
Achor Donald Trump himself is that you
can tell on some level that they don't
believe the own thing there lies that
they're telling like they just simply
don't care and their audience doesn't
really care because they feel like as
long as I'm scoring points on the
opponent as long as I'm dunking on
liberals then I can say or do whatever I
want I can accuse Hillary Clinton of
running a pedophilia ring out of a pizza
shop because the end goal is that I've
made mean things about Hillary Clinton
and that is a good and of itself and so
and I think that this has a like long
tail of it too I mean this this didn't
come out of nowhere I'm I'm very stuck
on the notion that climate change is
kind of like the like the original
conspiracy theory that once all
Republicans that kind of signed on to
the idea that climate change is a hoax
which is a conspiracy theory like it
opened up the door to whatever pizza
Gates Infowars you name it because
literally the top Republicans in this
country endorsed a pretty lurid
conspiracy theory that the majority of
like scientists around the world are
conspiring to hoax us about climate
change
yes good sons quaint or us Veronica they
used to be prisoners if you have the
goldwater isn't a small government
service so
Trump something ideological aside
people's cremated
where are in the to the question so the
question is basically are there any more
principled conservatives and and how is
there a way out for conservatism to
challenge the existing troll nation wing
of the conservative movement that's a
really good question I think underpins
this whole book and I think that my
answer to that is I think what happened
is they lost the argument the evidence
was stacked up against them I would
argue that most of the kind of general
conservative arguments about what's good
for people and good for society have
lost empirically they've lost the
popular vote they've lost in some
fundamental way and they know it and so
it's difficult I think for them to
continue on continuing on and I would
actually say someone like Paul Ryan
would be arguably a principled
conservative in the sense that I think
that he actually does believe that tax
cuts for the wealthy are good for
society in some way but even then he's
he kind of started to become part of
what became troll nation and that he
pretended to believe that it was good
for poor people or and it was good for
even middle-class people that he kind of
pretended to believe a discredited
theory theory of trickle-down economics
and I think that's what happened to them
is they had a bunch of series of
arguments and principles they failed one
after another and then rather than admit
defeat they started to embrace this kind
of neo list ik politics and and Paul
Ryan's a good figure to sort of see that
happen too because on one hand he has an
ideology on the other hand he sold it
out completely to trumpism because he
knew I think on some level he couldn't
win any other way and it's also I think
I mean I think it's
it's not just liberals that troll nation
turns their targets on no yeah in fact
one thing that's kind of alarming in
some red states is that the Republican
Party itself is being subject to
increasingly crazy like attacks from the
right and and I'm from Texas originally
and you can definitely see it going on
in Texas there's a group called empower
Texans
they are using dark money like from oil
billionaires in this state there's a lot
of extremely right-wing oil billionaires
in Texas who are willing to spend a lot
of money secretly and they spend most of
it primary Republicans in state
legislature they don't spend it trying
to beat Democrats they don't have to it
Democrats have been gerrymandered out of
power in that state so instead they
target people like the Texas Speaker of
the House Joe Straus who was kind of an
old school business Republican who
wasn't really interested in as much in
these culture war politics and and they
basically have effectively pushed him
out of his speakership and that's
happening in Texas I would argue that
that was happening to a large extent in
Wisconsin I think there's you can see it
happen in Ohio and what it is is is this
effort to sort of make all conservative
politics just this sort of all-out
fundamentalist culture war it is it an
Achilles heel
of that kind of politics that they
actually can't govern yeah
I mean they have no interest in
governing right I mean like governing I
think at us at its core is still based
in this sort of like general idea for
the common good and I think they've
rejected that as an ideal there's a
really fascinating study that you talk
about is public opinion quarterly you
talked about why troll nation actually
posits the ideas that they do and
they're asked questions in different
ways can you relate that where they're
at if they're it's about Barack Obama's
birth certificate oh yeah I found that
fascinating yeah they're very revealing
I don't have the exact study in front of
me right now but there has been research
that shows that if you ask conservatives
if they believe Barack Obama was born in
the United States it sort of depends on
how the question is framed if if you
frame it as we're doing a trivia quiz
about how knowledgeable you are about
politics conservatives will accurately
say that Barack Obama was born in Hawaii
if you frame it in terms of culture war
politics they will say he was born in
Kenya or not in the United States so
it's clear that on some level believing
that Barack Obama is concealing where he
was born
isn't a sincere belief but what it is is
a way to stick it to liberals and to
sort of show your tribal affiliation
more questions
that holding is its own defense like the
woman for the walls defense and my
little you can't criticize me on ethical
grounds because I'm just doing it so why
do they say they're only doing it for
the walls um I would say that's a really
good example of what I think is going on
in this political correctness debate
which is again it goes back to the
notion that the right knows that they
can't defend their arguments on their
own merits so they find ways to promote
their arguments without having to
actually defend them and one way they do
it is say you know I'm only being
politically incorrect I'm only trying to
get a rise out of you and if you react
negatively that's on you because it's a
way to deflect the argument you know
they say something racist you say well
I'm gonna argue with you on that and
they go it was just for the lulz so they
got to advance the racist argument
without actually having to defend the
racist argument and I think to a certain
extent these sort of these trolling
events on campuses where Milo or charles
murray or somebody goes to do a speech
on campus and draws out protests they're
doing the same thing which is they're
trying to make the argument about their
right to speak or their right to be
provocative without actually discussing
what they're trying to actually say in
their provocative arguments it it allows
them to romanticize what they're doing
without actually having to defend it
total questions please yes sir yes how
so often people journalist official here
or elsewhere
[Music]
that sounds like it's really like I
think the two things are one yeah legal
people who actually have cultural
knowledge to begin with I think one of
the most frustrating things is is all
these people who've never like lived
amongst apparently my tribe is this that
I grew up and is this like exotic group
of people you know maybe ask someone
like me to cover them second of all is
cover all of them like this way of only
talking to working-class white people
it's creating this very distorted vision
talk to the business owners talk to the
rich people that voted for Trump talk to
people that are gonna make your readers
uncomfortable because maybe they look a
little bit more like them you know
they're well off they have a college
degree they voted for Trump and that's a
lot of term voters like so often
so does there anymore cross
pollenization to maybe a few select your
reporters your likes vacation
photographer salon and so you know those
work yeah I think that would be released
fall I mean that would be one way to do
it especially since local papers are so
often failing because they don't have
any financial support gosh maybe kick a
little bit of that New York Times
Washington Post democracy dies in
darkness money their way right just but
is there also a posture to follow up in
your question is there also sort of a
responsibility then to look to flip the
idea as well cuz I think that both I can
do both sides there are cliches that
head in both directions I mean we kind
of know what a lot of people think about
the New York liberal elite is there is
there sort of a benefit to perhaps
taking that idea and turning it around
as well
well I would like to see you know I mean
there's been a couple of efforts to
respond to this criticism of the times
and other papers by profiling Clinton
voters but those efforts have focused on
also white well off the stereotype of
the Clinton voter and the reality of the
Clinton voter is not that I would like
to see some profiles of the actual
diversity of Clinton voters and and not
just Clinton voters like Democrats
generally but you know if you're gonna
profile the Trump voter than the obvious
inverse of that is the majority of
voters who voted for Hillary Clinton
which was a diverse coalition and I
don't think that that diversity is
reflected in the media at all is there
is I think there's do you think there's
an assumption that when someone says
working-class person they they generally
in the media mean a white person cuz
yeah I think that's been proven that's
really problem that
you see people say working-class person
and they mean white person and sometimes
they'll say white working-class and then
even that doesn't excuse it in my
opinion because again you're you're
hiding the fact that the majority of or
not the majority but like the class of
people we call working-class is a
racially diverse group of people and
like black and Latino and Asian
working-class people are just not well
portrayed in the media they are hidden
completely and and the reality is
especially when you look at like labor
organization efforts right now is you
know the face of working-class labor is
female and it's not why you had a
question right here about how full
nation emerged in part from the failures
of the right wing
ideas policy is arguments but do they
believe that those ideas and arguments
and policies have an impact available I
in readings were on the right in comment
sections and such they never
acknowledged I can't crack open people's
skulls I don't see what's in their head
I've judged from the behavior and the
behavior shows increasingly a lack of
that least enthusiasm to defend their
own ideas I mean you you turn on Fox
News and I mean it's true that both
MSNBC and Fox News both salon and
National Review whatever you want to do
like we spent a lot of time obsessing
over what the other side is about I mean
a wrote a book about the other side but
I I think that I I'm stunned by the
utter lack of willingness to like really
argue for and engage ideas on the right
and I think it it shows at least a scent
like maybe they don't acknowledge it to
themselves but there's at least a sense
that there's no point anymore
wasn't there a report that came out
after the Romney campaign which talked
about an automated autopsy after the
Romney campaign which did talk about how
they needed to genuinely change their
their approach to voters in terms of
their ideas yeah yeah the RNC autopsy a
lot of that was sort of them aimed at
engaging the idea that if they if they
promoted their ideas correctly they
could get more minority voters and right
and I think like the the ideal person
for that was like susana Martinez from
New Mexico did that get her name right
she she actually kind of tried she was
like small government low taxes and and
was actually kind of out there trying to
promote the idea that Latino voters
would like these ideas and she lost
completely like the like Republican
voters took one look at her and her
strategy and was like nope voted for
Donald Trump instead so I mean I think
that tells you all you need to know
about that
let me get someone else asked a question
I'll come back to go right ahead please
looking at looking at the the trend line
of trolls where are we in the trend line
where's the market where's the market on
trolls right now gosh I don't know it's
so hard to tell with like the Russian
bots noise in there really like it seems
like trolling got worse and now we're
only just beginning to grapple with the
fact that a whole bunch of them were
like fake that said I think at least
until recently the rise I think in my
experience and this is just anecdotal
and just my observation is not backed up
with any scientific evidence I feel like
it was getting worse because like a lot
of like older people like learned how to
use Twitter and so there was this like
many of them use it very well in very
positive ways like of course of course
but you know you're outwardly 5 or 6
years ago your average Fox News viewer
was not on Twitter now they are and
again that's just personal anecdote but
I think that more Americans generally
are on social media and that's created
more trolling behavior on social media
but on the flip side I think a lot of
them were kind of trolling their
relatives and friends to begin with
right back here
so what is the world my
so what does he what does they cross
your fingers post Trump pence world look
like on your prognostication event
I thought we learned not to do that
after 2016 claimer past results are no
guarantee to ensure performance well I
don't know I really might I'll give you
my hope in my fear my hope is I look at
these kids and from the park the
Parkland kids and that's my best hope
for the future is that I see these young
people and there's so many of them that
that genuinely want a politics of
progress genuinely want a politics of
change and genuinely have the optimism
that we can kind of get past these
tribal politics and think of solutions
that actually make for better tomorrow
worst-case scenario is Redux 2008 right
like Barack Obama was elected in no
small part because conservatives and
Republicans were demoralized after the
failures of the Bush administration
liberals were fired up and they elected
Barack Obama and everything was great
and then we got complacent it and they
got angry and they got resentful and
rageful and gave us Donald Trump as
basically fun functionally an act of
revenge for for Barack Obama and I'm not
sure that I see enough evidence that
that cycle that we found a way to break
that cycle of vengeance and seeing
politics as kind of conservative seeing
politics as vengeance and liberals only
kind of getting it together when they
feel they've lost I don't know y'all are
in the room you're like I hope I can
sell this book and convince some people
it's so like maybe think about politics
differently and hopefully because that's
the only way it can change right
register to vote registered entities
we go to this gentleman person I'll come
to you are you saying that most did not
so the clerk did those people just not
believe Donald Trump even the ones who
voted for him anyway you're saying
good I think
well I guess I kept my question would be
like what did they believe about him and
I think that that's a more like a better
way to put it which is like Donald Trump
changes what he thinks one minute to a
next like and he will openly lie and I
think his supporters know that and get
that about him and they just don't care
but I do think that they believe that
he's a racist and I do believe that they
believe that he's a sexist and I do
think that they believe that he's gonna
be a warrior for their tribe and that's
all they care about and they don't care
that he's against bombing Syria one
second and then bombing Syria the next
second they don't carry that he said
he'll protect Medicare and Medicaid on
the trail and then he gets in office and
sets up Paul Ryan he's a Paul Ryan to
slash these benefits programs the fact
that every two seconds what he thinks
about daca changes they don't care about
that as long as he actually continues to
be racist to Latinos and continues to
assert that real America is this this
kind of white Christian identity
politics I hope that clarifies because I
mean he's not somebody who has policy
beliefs but he has somebody who has
cultural beliefs - my childhood and what
roles were actually murderous downside
than they were during RIMPAC geez these
are students and acid in their faces and
even killing them do you think that
trono trial a troll nation and even
Charlotte stone even the Nazis that are
coming out online that we haven't it's
some move over because I don't think
what happened to Little Rock could
happen today what do you think I hope
you're right and I think that there's a
lot of evidence for what you're saying
and I think that that's true I also know
that a lot of the times these kind of
hate movements sort of rise up and
bubble and bubble and then spill over
and surprise people so you know they're
not they're not burning churches until
they are right and that said I mean I
often joke and I'm only half joking that
we're lucky in our opponents and that
you know the younger people of this
generation despite like the alt-right
being a you know the faces of the the
Charlottesville unite the right guys
were more younger the majority of people
that voted for Trump are older and I
think that that takes a lot of piss out
of them like it takes young people to
burn churches and riot in the street and
pick up guns and start revolutions and I
do think that the younger generation
while there is a subset of young men
that are embracing neo Nazism and really
going to the mat with this I think
they're very small subset of their
generation and I don't think that they
have the numbers to cause the kind of
social chaos that you rightfully worry
about so take one more question if
someone's got one
right back here
overlap in spirit she buries his
Etheridge there's one nice off both
sides pushing hard and then the deep
state which is hilarious because the
right clips that you take during one
thing
let's take website keeps a string with
other things and we're going to be out
that they're both pushing like the same
exact narrative
it's like a week's remediate don't trust
it that's another one only trustees that
should create these verses and it's the
same exact behavior it's just once all
when I say I would have left and
blending like Obama's evolve Hillary's
evil vote for this crazy person you know
transpose so is it the question I think
is please correct me if I'm wrong is
there overlap at the fringes and how
does that speak to the idea of troll
nation I mean I think that that's true
and we've seen that happen and there's
definitely political theorists of
propaganda who could do a lot better job
than I like discussing the way that like
trolls and propagandists kind of exploit
these cultural tensions and and prey on
left-wing fringe types to sow chaos
right I think what I would say though is
that the difference as far as I can tell
is that the crazy
Seth rich conspiracy theory right has
traction in their mainstream media that
is not true on the flip side like for
instance as it became more and more
evident that Julian Assange is clearly
on some level a lackey of the Russian
government like liberal mainstream
liberal sources abandoned him like as a
source like in mass you don't see the
Guardian you know really defending
Julian Assange anymore or New York or
salon or places like that whereas these
right-wing conspiracy theories are on
Fox News like Sean Hannity was pumping
that Seth rich conspiracy theory on
primetime television and you do not see
the same thing on the left with you're
never gonna see Rachel Maddow talking
about the deep state
that's actually since you mentioned Seth
rich wanted uh I want to get people from
a taste of the book do you want to read
a little bit from the Seth rich section
that we've carefully marked in advance
and just happening we just happened to
land on that so thank you so I think
that would be a nice a nice way to wrap
things up sure sure so if you'll indulge
me firm in it it's just a couple pages
from the book but Sean Hannity of Fox
News mainstays since 1996 made a bold
attempt in 2017 to change all that by
getting his show deeply involved in a
conspiracy theory accusing Hillary
Clinton of killing a democratic national
committee staffer named Seth Ridge the
whole debacle wasn't just an assault on
truth it was a vile assault on basic
human decency and yet in another sign of
the moral rot that has eaten away at the
American right Hannity hasn't really
paid a price for the role he played in
tormenting the family of a murder victim
rich died in the early hours of the
morning in July 10th 2016 a couple of
weeks before a set of emails which we
now know were stolen by the Russian
government from DNC staffers were leaked
on the internet through WikiLeaks at the
time of his murder rich was providing
tech support for the DNC the 27 year old
had gone out drinking at a favorite bar
in his Washington DC neighborhood and
was murdered in an apparent robbery gone
wrong while out on the street a block
from his home in the wee hours of the
morning right-wing conspiracy theorists
aided by some left-wing sorts who hate
the Clintons reacted to this tragedy by
trying to argue that rich and not the
Russian government was the source who
leaked the emails to WikiLeaks and that
he was murdered for it
on its surface the argument doesn't make
sense
conspiracy theorists want you to believe
that rich was a whistleblower trying to
shine light on the DNC's efforts to rig
the primaries so Clinton beat Bernie
Sanders but there was no evidence to
support this rigging accusation in the
emails that were leaked WikiLeaks wanted
people to believe that and sadly many
Sanders supporters were suckered by the
accusations but a close examination of
the emails found at best that some
people in the DNC were grumpy that
Sanders wouldn't concede the race the
after Clinton had racked up a vote count
sufficient to secure the nomination it
doesn't make sense that a whistleblower
would leak some
that is an evidence and even if it was
evidence then such a person would
probably prefer leaking it to a major
newspaper rather than a shady operation
like WikiLeaks but a bunch of people
were are deep but a whole bunch of
people are deeply invested in denying
that the Russian government is behind
the hacked emails that group includes
Julian Assange the head of WikiLeaks who
went on Twitter to insinuate that rich
was the leak or even though it's damn
near 100% that he was not and if rich
was the leaker Assange could prove it
his failure to do so even after rich was
murdered is just one more piece of
evidence that this is a disgusting
exploitation of a violent crime to stoke
a conspiracy theory that group also
includes Trump supporters and the
portion of Sanders supporters so you've
got taken in by Russian propaganda and
don't want to admit to themselves or
others that they were fooled the south
rich conspiracy theories and Alex Jones
level pile of [ __ ] but I got a lift
in the mainstream media when Hannity
started using his Fox News show one of
the most popular cable news shows in the
country to start selling this nonsense
to his gullible audience Kennedy had
hinted at the south rich conspiracy
theory multiple times in the months
since a young man was murdered but in
May 2017 he went all-in
that's when Fox News reported that a
private investigator named rod wheeler
allegedly claimed that Seth rich had
been communicating with WikiLeaks before
his death that was untrue the reports
that wheeler had been hired by the rich
family were false he had been hired by a
wealthy Trump supporter the family put
out a press statement flatly denying
wheelers claims and then we learned
himself
sued the network saying Fox News had
fabricated some of his statements and I
just want to pause here to say it was so
hard to keep track myself with all this
stuff no matter hannity had picked up
the stick and he was running with it on
his fox news show his radio show and
Twitter account Hannity relentlessly
promoted this conspiracy theory and one
of trumps own lawyers Jay Sekulow even
joined in on one segment on Fox News
Kennedy's purpose was obvious if he
could convince his audience that rich
had leaked the DNC emails to WikiLeaks
then they had an excuse to dismiss the
reams of real-world evidence that showed
that hackers paid by the Russian
government did it
Hannity didn't even try to hide that
this was his purpose explosive
developments in the mysterious murder of
former DNC staff
Southridge that could completely shatter
the narrative that in fact WikiLeaks was
working with the Russians or there was
collusion between the Trump campaign and
the Russians he breathlessly declared on
Fox News on May 16th the timing of this
is important to understand Hannity's
desperation on May 9th Trump had fired
FBI director James Comey in an obvious
bid to derail the Russia investigation
on May 11th Trump admitted to an NBC
News acre less Lester Holt that his
purpose was obstruction of justice
saying when I decided to just do it I
said to myself you know this Russia
thing with Trump and Russia's a made-up
story on May 17th robert muller was
appointed special counsel to investigate
any potential collusion between the
Trump campaign and the Russian
government to commit illegal acts such
as stealing email in order to tip the
election as of this writing Muller has
secured two guilty pleas and two
indictments of campaign staff the rich
gambit was a pathetic ploy by hannity to
tap into the conspiracy theory minded
nature of 21st century conservative
america in an effort to poison his
audience against accepting any
forthcoming revelations about the trump
administration's involvement with the
russia conspiracy to manipulate the
american election but it was so
over-the-top that even foxnews turned on
hannity on May 23rd Hannity reluctantly
agreed to stop embarrassing the network
by flogging the story but he still kept
at it on his radio show and on Twitter
it turned out in fact there was a
conspiracy but not among Democrats to
kill Seth rich instead it was reported
in August that Edie Bukowski the wealthy
Trump supporter backing wheeler had been
in contact with the White House and Fox
News about his efforts to claim the DNC
and Clinton had rich murdered these sort
of political games have real costs and
not just on election outcomes the rich
family has suffered greatly because of
the exploitation of Seth Rich's murder
every day we woke up to new headlines
new lives new factual errors new people
approaching us to take advantage of us
since s legacy Mary and Joel rich says
parents wrote in a Washington Post
editorial on May 23rd it just won't stop
the amount of pain in English this has
caused us is unbearable with every
conspirator flare-up we are forced to
relive sess murder and a small piece of
his dies as more obsessive memories torn
away from us a few things demonstrate
the moral depravity and Neil ISM that
has swept over 21st century
of America more than the widespread
embrace of conspiracy theories such as
birtherism and pizza gate the
proliferation of lies is rapidly
degrading public discourse which is why
lol nothing matters has become the dark
internet joke of our time worse as the
story of Seth rich and his family shows
real people are being hurt by the
rapidly growing pile of [ __ ]
unfortunately there's no real remorse
from troll nation which means we can
only expect this problem to expand until
engulfs us all so Amanda thank you for
being here thank you for writing the
book
everyone please feel free to stay here
in the room talk to Amanda buy your two
copies of the book please
[Applause]